thanks to brilliant org for sponsoring
this episode hey crazies in physics we
talk about Newton's laws a lot like a
lot a lot but I wouldn't want to
actually use Newtonian mechanics to
model something like a double pendulum
it's just too complicated so today we're
gonna be learning about a powerful
alternative Lagrangian mechanics
mechanics
you mean like the people that fix stuff
what do they have to do with Newton's
laws actually a lot but that's not what
we're talking about mechanics is a
branch of physics dealing specifically
with motion it's the set of mathematical
tools we use to predict the path objects
will take and there are a lot of ways we
can do that Newtonian mechanics
Lagrangian mechanics Hamiltonian
mechanics and even quantum mechanics
can't we just pick one and forget the
rest I wouldn't recommend that they all
have their own realms of usefulness for
example if you've got a very simple
scenario Newtonian mechanics is
definitely the way to go
Newton's laws of motion are all about
forces don't have any forces Newton's
first law says you get steady motion in
a straight line is there a downward
gravity Newton's second law says you get
an acceleration that's just freefall but
maybe a projectile as long as you can
keep track of all the forces acting on
something and you know some initial
conditions you can predict the motion
cause and effect is built right into the
laws is there a ball and a ramp gravity
pulls it down and friction makes it roll
do you have a simple pendulum the
tension makes it swing in an arc
unfortunately not all scenarios are that
simple consider the double pendulum this
thing is a beast it's a beast there are
two objects each with their own forces
the top one has three forces in the
bottom one has two for a total of five
three of those five are changing in time
it's the quintessential example for
chaos theory slightly different initial
conditions can result in wildly
different paths enter Lagrangian
mechanics named after Giuseppe Luigi
Lagrangian I mean Joseph Louis Lagrange
who published them in seventeen
in Newton's laws if you know where this
pendulum is and what it's doing then the
forces tell you what happens next then
what happens after that then what
happens after that and so on a cause
leads to an effect but Lagrangian self
what if we could consider the entire
path at once hmm
if we want to do that we're gonna need
to look for a pattern there must be
something that all paths share as the
expression goes though nobody lives in a
vacuum Lagrange's to the timeline
LeGrande Avella pecans in the late 1700s
but for MA was already dabbling with
this in 1662 and he built his ideas on
the works of even al-haytham from 10:21
nobody lives in a vacuum anyway for Moss
principle states out of all the paths is
available white always takes the path
that requires the least amount of time
but Newton's laws got published only a
couple decades later and it was clear
that matter doesn't move the same way
light does so LeGrande a problem if
matter doesn't follow the path of least
time what path doesn't follow he needed
to find a pattern that all paths share
pattern forces aren't gonna help us with
that we're gonna need energy and work in
simplest terms energy is the amount of
stuff that could happen and work is the
amount of stuff that does happen mind
you we didn't actually know any of that
at the time as far as Lagrange's
concerned it was just a useful quantity
without a direction something we'd call
a scalar quantity we wouldn't find
meaning in it or even call it energy
until the 1800s how is this supposed to
help us put the grungy mechanics it's
the basis for the whole thing these days
were aware of a lot of different types
of energy but they can be organized into
two major categories kinetic energy and
potential energy kinetic energy is
associated with motion and potential
energy with location they're essentially
the scalar versions of the vectors
velocity and position if energy is the
amount of stuff that could happen and
stuff happening usually involves some
kind of path then it stands to reason
these two things are related to each
other
LeGrande major categories of
kinetic and potential and combine them
into a single quantity we now call the
Lagrangian if we map out all possible
lagrangian's for an object across space
we can add the values along a possible
path and get an idea of its efficiency
we call this efficiency the action and
it's a really big deal the action is
that pattern we're looking for pattern
there are a lot of paths available but
it only takes one of them the paths with
the smallest variation in the action ok
there I have been using a bunch of $10
words let me explain say you've got a
graph like this how much it's changing
is given by its slope the place where
the slope is zero there's no change and
there is very little variation around
that place yes this is a math thing a
change of zero can occur at one of three
places a minimum a maximum or a saddle
point we call these places stationary
points knowing that we can write the
principle of stationary action which
tells us objects will take the path with
the smallest variation paths around the
real one show very little difference in
their total actions so that's the path
the object takes so wait does it check
all the possible path is to see which
one to take don't be ridiculous
just because we can use this model to
predict where the object will go that
doesn't mean the object can it just does
whatever it's gonna do we're the ones
coming up with rules and patterns it's
just a mathematical tool for making
predictions remember while Lagrangian
mechanics might consider the path as a
whole Newtonian mechanics doesn't it's
still valid and has causality built into
it but if Lagrangian mechanics works so
well why don't we just use that all the
time do you always use the most powerful
tool for the job I mean would you use a
sledge hammer to open a walnut
[Music]
no of course not
anyway there's a better way to visualize
this stuff Newtonian mechanics is done
in three dimensional position space all
three axes represent normal everyday
position measured in meters or miles or
whatever your distance unit of choice is
in Lagrangian mechanics we use something
called generalized coordinates which is
a terrible name because they tend to be
very specific to the scenario I prefer
to call them degrees of freedom for
example this simple pendulum only has
one degree of freedom the angle of the
string you could very easily show the
motion on a single axis the double
pendulum has two degrees of freedom the
angle of each of the two strings its
motion could be tracked on a
two-dimensional grid each point on this
grid represents a possible configuration
of the pendulum so we call this
configuration space it's not a real
space like the 3d space we live in it's
just an abstract representation you can
even include a speed or momentum axis to
get an idea of motion here's the simple
pendulum in something we call phase
space yes you're technically doing
Hamiltonian mechanics at that point but
there really isn't much difference so
what's Lagrangian mechanics it's just
another way of looking at a physical
system in normal Newtonian mechanics we
start by looking at a single moment then
step forward or backward according to
the rules of cause and effect in
Lagrangian mechanics we look at the path
as a whole between two events according
to the principle of stationary action
the path taken by the object is the one
with very little variation in energy
over time if your system is really
simple or there are complex forces like
friction involve Newtonian mechanics is
probably gonna be your best option if
your system is in the sweet spot in
between maybe try out Lagrangian
mechanics it's especially useful in
quantum mechanics where the concept of a
force almost completely loses meaning
Lagrangian mechanics is just a tool
whether or not you use it is up to you
so what do you think of Lagrangian
mechanics fun weird both let us know in
the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like wacky who help keep the
show going with their generous support
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy becoming great at
math and science doesn't have to be dull
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app with a hands-on approach there
are over 50 courses full of storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve if you watch this video you
probably like their course on classical
mechanics it even includes a quiz about
Lagrangian mechanics and how it makes
use of energy to solve problems although
I'd recommend starting at the beginning
of the course you know work up to the
hard stuff brilliant is built for
ambitious and curious people who want to
excel at problem-solving and
understanding the world you'll unravel
concepts bit by bit and discover deep
truths in unexpected places if this
sounds like a service you'd like to use
go to brilliant org slash science asylum
today the first 200 subscribers will get
20% off an annual subscription the
featured comment comes from Dillo Phi
who said the delayed choice experiment
is still mysterious after this video
that's okay
but it's only mysterious because none of
us actually understand it just remember
that it's not mysterious because of
magic anyway thanks for watching
[Music]